foreign
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
I took some pictures got their insurance
registration information it's on camera
Sally we got that
yeah
all right we're gonna go down here for a
minute all right you guys sat here yeah
okay
see are these Witnesses these are their
uh
their rides
and they said it felt like they were hit
and I looked down there and there's a
silver car up by that telephone pole
yeah I looked at their car and saw they
have their whole front assembly I saw
that like
theirs so I look and there's somebody
running up here from another vehicle I'm
not sure if it's their sun or whoever
but they said the other guy when their
daughter went to check on him because
that's I guess who owns a white car so
he couldn't even stand up
so obviously he was it appears he was
intoxicating I didn't go talk to him
either he stayed up here so except for
the actual incidentally because all I
saw was that car flying
what direction of travel were you going
we were heading north they were heading
south okay so you've seen it on that
side of the road yeah perfect and we've
pulled over we saw him stop right there
we're like that ain't good so we're
gonna do a weekend to keep them from
your head again or go ahead
problem
now we're right here behind this fire
truck opposite lane so
I appreciate it man no problem all right
still need us to be here or hold on
what's like
yeah we got a witness to seeing the uh
vehicle come through the media we got
nowhere to be so if you need us
hang tight for a minute
oh
did you see what happened he did
he did okay yeah
you can stay in the car if you just want
to roll the window down stay warm Matt
it's freezing out here at this crosswind
in these Open Fields man
so we're we were traveling hold on a
second let's get a second here man sorry
my hands are nice
first of all uh can I get your ID by
chance
okay put this one on your left hand
good
you'll learn to get some gloves
I have some of my back pocket well no
you want winter gloves for
this stuff
what kind of dog did she get bit by
yours or someone else's
oh so family yeah
yeah
ouch
how bad
yeah
the same with my wife same way like I
know friends I have them and they're
always great great but you always hear
about these isolated incidents and we're
like yeah we'll never never owned
no they don't that's the problem I mean
I've got a rod and I'm still right
yeah
it is you're right
cut off
all right
not the other one yeah um
I'd recommend going to the hospital if
you could convince your mom to go to the
hospital she seemed a little stubborn
she's ready to get home
yeah they're not far away
um we're just going to talk to them real
quick see how what they want us to
handle because the circumstances of this
accident
um
so when they get here we're gonna make
contact with them real quick
MSP so we had David that's already where
the drivers already went over checked on
on the parents and they said they're
okay they're just shook it up so what I
suggest just once the adrenaline starts
to run down they may have some more pain
and if they need to go to the hospital
or whatever
my mom yeah the seat belt she said where
the seatbelt come across is where she's
sore
awesome that's my opinion if she doesn't
want to go with the ambulance to avoid
that bill or whatever I would just make
sure that she still goes
or keep an eye on her and make sure
because you just never know what's gonna
what could happen because if the car
rolled over
yeah I mean if if she hit her head you
know that could have easily
um
no are they not wanting to go no okay
okay we're these are the uh son-in-law
daughter-in-law son um
yeah so these people are with them so
we're just letting them know to keep an
eye and and make sure that
because if she hit her head or or that
he hit his head you know the onsets of
symptoms could trigger later
so if they should have anything to
change and I both I made both of them
aware of each other's symptoms and
things they're going to be sore where
the seatbelt hit them at
um the next couple days changes at all I
told them they really should go get
checked out at some point so they do it
down there yeah so they just had to go
somewhere down there is way back down uh
we're heading down South Bend actually
so
yeah and that's what I would recommend I
would I would probably have them checked
out just just because I roll over you
don't know when you hit your head what's
going to happen
right and a lot of those symptoms they
may be having now might be masked by the
panic and everything else that's been
going on
um so I always recommend that if you get
an accent be checked out at some point
so but I advised him perfectly with you
guys if I need to change with them or
you notice anything different or they're
not acting right all of a sudden
you know what unit what get his
ambulance
make sure he's life or Pride
Pride medical level
you just got just all you gotta do is
just put down Pride that way you can
document in your report that Pride
responded and then they refused medical
they were seen But refused for their
treatment just shows that they were here
thank you
okay and as soon as MSP like I said they
get down here we'll try to get them
stay please
yeah
yep so that's all we're waiting on and
they were coming from Stadium Drive area
so it shouldn't be much longer for us to
make contact with them okay all right
yeah he's fine as of right now he's fine
anyways from what I hear said he wasn't
even in the driver's seat
okay
yeah you can ask him that if he asked
him what he's seen so he could document
what where did he get out of the car at
on the right side okay
I don't think
okay all right I'll be right back
or something I'm not do you have one
Rick all right can we grab that yeah
no but I got a double blanket that I was
using
don't tell nobody
yeah it's two blankets wrapped up if you
open them up it's just a big bath
blanket there's two of them
if you want to get him up to the car
what can I do to help find a trunk
button for me
Hood
[Music]
okay I'm gonna take some photos real
quick